this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening your Savages it's
Monday the 13th of March the joint is
brought to you by Mint mobile listen are
you paying a ridiculous amount of money
for your phone plan save more and spend
less with mint mobile mint is the first
company to sell wireless cell service
online only get a new phone plan
starting at ready 15 a month that's
right 15 a month with all that extra
cash laying around you can treat
yourself to something very nice all
plans come with unlimited talk text and
high-speed data on The Late nation's
largest 5G Network who's better than
them nobody and you can switch easily in
minutes so do me a favor to get your new
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com
Joey again that's mintmobile.com
Joey got your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at mintmobile.com
Joey the joint is also brought to you by
Chip Chip Kelly ho [__] DraftKings
it's UFC 286
live from London it's Leon Edwards
against Kamara Usman for the
championship fight place your bets on
DraftKings Sportsbook D official sports
betting partner UFC new customers let's
get the party started bet five dollars
and get 200 bonus bets instantly all
users can take the MMA action to the
next level with DraftKings same game
parlays but the total bet whether
they're going to get knocked out
disqualified they're going to win by
decision this is the way to go but it
starts with you download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app today use code Joey bet
five dollars on any UFC 286 fight and
get 200 instantly in bonus bets that's
code Joey
j-o-e-y only at DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner in the
UFC got to be 21 over the most eligible
States but age varies by jurisdiction
eligibility and positive restrictions
apply see draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details and
state-specific responsible gaming
gambling resources you got a gambling
problem call 1-800 Gambler or text
four six seven three nine in New York or
call 877
h-o-p-e-n-y Hope New York bet
responsibly let's get this party started
it's Monday morning and I got stuff to
do and people to see
[Music]
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
thank you
okay
what's happening you bad Savages it's
Monday the 13th of March the month is
rolling right along like I knew it would
you know what I'm saying it's a
beautiful week to be alive it's a
beautiful day to be alive we're back
Mike and I were talking about the weed
situation in Jersey how he went to a
weed store last week in the [__] line
ended in Philadelphia that's how you
know and it's so weird how the weed is
blowing up and and I'm really happy that
the reefer has blown up I was telling
Mike I remember when the pharmacy opened
up in L.A
and I refuse to go to those places I had
a dealer I was stuck with him you know I
fought to the end but between the
lollipops and the cookies and the cakes
you know he didn't he wasn't a baker so
I was like [__] it let me go to the
pharmacy dog I was like a kid in the
[__] candy store it was phenomenal
like I told Mike for about six months
and I looked at my credit card
statements and I'm like what the [__]
was this you know you went from buying
an eight to fifty bucks to spending 220
a day now
so if I was smoking an eighth in two
days I was going down there and dropping
200 just to have an x-ray the weed was
so funny every time I went in there they
had ice cream and lip balm can you
imagine just putting lip balm on them
and getting [__] high they had
everything at the [__] pharmacy but
then like I said I realized how much I
was [__] spending my wife pulled me
aside and she's like you put five grand
on a card
in a month
and she was hot she goes you're gonna
[__] pay that back I paid it back
everything worked itself out and I had a
good time doing it I and I'm I'm happy
that New York has finally been legalized
in New York City and it's finally been
legalized in New Jersey and all the
other spots and the wheat stores making
money and people have somewhere to go
but in California right now
the tax on reefer is so [__] high
like when people walk into a store and
they walk like I told Mike they get in
their car you know they open up the bag
maybe they want to drink the [__] CBD
water like I used to get and also you
see the receipt there and you see that
you spent 125 dollars but you dropped 60
in taxes
and you're like what the [__] is this
and you know when you go to these weed
stores now I mean I don't I have not
been to a weed store yet in Jersey they
say there's one in Neptune that I'm
thinking of stopping and just saying
hello but when you go to a weed store
what I'm getting is that they're really
packed
the lines are [__] the ones up
Northern New Jersey it's impossible you
got to be there at 10 in the morning you
can't have a [__] day job to get weed
you got to be there all [__] day like
getting Barbecue in Austin it's a it's a
three-hour experience
so but it's I'm happy but I'll tell you
what's going to happen like in L.A right
now when you look at those receipts
you're like
fifty dollars in taxes 54. because I'm
buying you know Recreation
Medical
they I don't know there is there is more
of a
medical is THC controlled
like the THC levels are controlled and I
don't know if it's more expensive you
know I remember going to Denver and you
walked in and then when you walked into
the big wheat store there was like a a
medical and a recreational side I know
that like the recreational side didn't
sell Edibles over a hundred I don't know
I I know that there's little rules but
you know it's it's gonna in L.A right
now people just going back to the black
market people buying I have a friend
here that buys pounds from L.A he shows
me the links that he gets and he gets
pretty good weed for 2600 a pound 2200 a
pound you know the the prices are going
down but he's he's a genius because he
sells it in joints so I told him I said
you can't like you can't take a laughing
gas and really get the full value of it
in joints and I'll tell you why because
it's that good
it's that [__] good between us
you don't need a [__] joint
the guava Kush you don't need a joint of
that oh my God the one-headed the
tremendous you don't need a joint of
that you'll roll a joint to be cool but
it's it's you don't need to join it
that's the mistake I had when you buy an
eighth of pot especially anything over
25 milligrams uh 25 26 it's really bong
hit weed it's really bungee weed you
know uh for you people who don't know
when you see these rappers with these
blunts all day they're smoking shitty
weed yeah I'm telling you right now this
they they buy weed to smoke and they
roll ton of those [__] things listen
I love smoking reefer
but the price is a reef a [__] you
know astronomical
and yeah it's listen right now
like I was saying some of these kids
that are buying weed these young guys
they never really had a dealer
they've never really had a dealer you if
you were 18 in California 20 years ago
you never had a dealer you walked into a
store and that's all you've known since
day one I always enjoyed the dealer
like I missed calling the guy like
getting paid on a Friday and calling the
guy and going I'll be there at six and
you stop and get a 12 pack you tell your
friends I'll be over there at seven and
you go to yeah you go to his house you
buy a [__] eighth you take a bong hit
you smoke some you talk some [__] and
you get in the car and you [__] drive
away and the whole time you're worried
that the cops are gonna pull you over
and [__] that's getting weird to me like
that's the fun day again weed but life
has changed and I [__] get it listen
I get it I don't listen I've always
loved going to a witch talk I am not
gonna lie to you [__] and tell
you that there is no but me at my age to
walk into anything I don't get excited
anymore like you know when you [__]
have to attend when you attend you went
to get a Hot Wheel you were [__]
excited all week like yeah that you know
I get [__] excited when I walk into a
weed store and especially like
I like the new end ones that are big and
everybody comes up to you with the
computer not to buy weeds just to see
what they've done with the reef of
business
what to see what they've how complicated
they've made it there was a place in L.A
called House of Pies love the place I
love that coconut custard pie I went
there twice
twice and I walked by there eighty times
a [__] week and wouldn't go back in
there because I had to go up through the
window hi Mike how are you good what
would you like Joey I'd like the coconut
custard pie okay write it down now the
coconut custard pie would be five feet
behind you
all you had to do is turn around take it
and cut it and give you the coconut
custard pie now they had a receipt they
give it to the chick the chick ran into
the back to the Mexican and you had to
wait 10 minutes for a piece of [__]
pie
crate pie but I'm not waiting you just
added a job to a job that wasn't needed
you just added a whole hike to the back
you could have just turned around and
cut a slice and put on a [__] Edition
give it to me I'm not that particular I
don't need a fancy [__] dish or
whatever they didn't even that you know
they didn't even dope it up or anything
when you go to these high-end weed
stores like and it happened right in
front of my [__] eyes
I was going to
the one read Store on Burbank Boulevard
they were the Russians
they would really take care of me they
were great people the guy was great to
me but when it came to high-end weed you
know if they were on Ventura Boulevard
I.E the ice cream shop but how I ended
up at the ice cream shop was across the
street from there there was a weed store
that was phenomenal
I was a customer that has just a minute
I moved to the valley and I loved them
the girls were hot the girls were cute
they were sweet they flirted with you
they [__] around with you they gave
you Deals they had a punch card they
were [__] they gave you samples of
[__] they would take you into the back
and show you the grow room it was just
and they would do it with anybody okay
if you went in there and you're like
this place was great come on let me show
you the grow room and you'd go back
there and be like you know again the kid
in the [__] candy store you'd be a
fat kid locked in a Carvel you know what
I'm saying like you like coconut
pistachio mint you know you like [__]
a kid so
and that place was tremendous like
I would get there at 10 o'clock
right when they opened there was an
Asian girl that was married and cool and
she had a kid and we talk all the time
about comedy and she went to the ice
house all the time and you know it was
just going in there they had juice I
used to go to a place when I first got
there that the [__] would serve
Bagels
the mother he was he was Jewish you know
come on this [__] had it down he
was a Russian Jew
when everybody else is opening at 10
this [__] opened at six
a.m and you know why because the city
employees were going in there
you would see City trucks parked there
all getting that [__] bagel and their
[__] joint oh my God it was like
one that's what Miley Cyrus used to go
with her brother
yeah that's when Miley would sit outside
and the brother would go in and get weed
there was some phenomenal little spots
but again
I didn't move on because of my loyalty
issues I moved on because they closed
this is strawberry
liquid IV [__] tremendous I love this
[__]
Daya
you know I wasn't my loyalty issues it
was that people would just go out of
[__] business just like that like the
Jewish guy that's where I used to get
the banana bread
that was the banana bread place she had
a cook in the back that made [__]
banana bread
they gave out bagels with locks
7 A.M and I'm not talking about shitty
Bagels I'm talking about this guy went
somewhere in the valley and got bagels
and he would get lox it was a ploy and
he [__] and it worked for him he got
shut down then there was the Armenians
by my house that were [__] tremendous
they got shut down the Russians always
stayed open but like I said the Russians
had great filters
the Russians had great Edibles like they
had the tubes I used to get and the
[__] punch bars and all that [__]
with the Russians the stuff what I'm
talking about now with the Asian girl
one day they just said we're closing for
30 days
okay I could live with that we're gonna
read
renovate okay I can live with that
and the next thing you know I went in
after a month and nobody was there
except for the manager and he pulled me
aside he's like yeah we got a new owner
and he's going 20 20 on us and [__] so
they had all computer pads and again you
walk in Hi how are you welcome to
[__] the green apple and you know
like uh what am I looking at how can you
go over here and you would go listen let
me get the strongest [__] and she would
go oh you know I don't know if I you
know you're like what are you talking
about no they became woke they became
very woke and very like you know and I'm
like yeah I want that okay uh do you
have payment yeah you have to pay her
she swipes to the card and her computer
thing and then she gives you like a
number
and then you sit there and then also
number 48 and you go up to the thing and
they just give you everything
you know but it went from me going up to
you going hey Mike you got something
good for me and you gonna [__] yeah hold
on and you taking a a basket out with
tongues with chopsticks and taking out a
bud and putting it down and having like
I just found my magnifying glass the
other day A Little Mac which I don't
care about a magnifying glass guys but
I'm telling you that they gave it to you
then that all that process got
eliminated
and they just they already had a Jarred
and already in the bag so I was there
for that you know so that took me
[__] for a loop when I went to the
same store I was buying [__] for a long
time and now they're [__] uh what do
you call that [__] they're already
pre-packaged and [__] they give you one
of those dead [__] pre-rolls and I
couldn't take that I didn't like that in
personal service I wanted it to be a
little smaller and to build the ones in
New York City now are supposedly huge
I saw a picture one in Jersey with
people with earphones
like people were there from I don't know
I don't know if weed was [__] made to
be all this but you know guys
we live in a new [__] world so
we reap what the [__] we sow
another thing came to mind this week
that I've been thinking about the a lot
of people haven't thought about it
third year since the pandemic
today is the 13th of [__] March the
World closed down on the 14th of March
and there was official on St Patty's Day
that year
three [__] years guys let me ask you
a question
how much has your life changed in three
years
do you think about it think about our
lives in three years since the pandemic
closed since the pandemic hit us three
[__] years
everything everything
changed the LA scene is no longer
they're all in Austin jumping up and
down at the mothership you know uh I'm
not there anymore you know there's a
bunch of people out there but that's not
what I'm talking about
how much have you changed honestly since
the pandemic your job
the people you hung out with
people that moved after the pandemic
your home
you know if you really think of like I
had to sit down the other day and bust a
newspaper out this is the this is the
disadvantages of getting high in the
afternoon
but sometimes you smoke pot and it hits
you harder than others like in the
morning I like to smoke pot before I go
to the red light sometimes early in the
morning like at 10 to get the sweat
going before Jiu Jitsu and guys they're
going that high and my mind runs away
with me right
and I was thinking about how much [__]
has changed in three [__] years in
our lives
people have changed a ton
used to remember being like April 17th a
month into it and not knowing what was
going to happen
how much fear we had like I was confused
I didn't know what the [__] was gonna
happen like we're going to be closed for
another month I started worrying about
money people around me were [__]
dying like people around me had no idea
what to do I didn't know what to do
nobody knew what the [__] to say we were
just stuck in our homes
figure it out for ourselves getting
scared by the minute by [__] ABC
Eyewitness News tonight let me tell you
something I have never watched
eyewitness news yet
this is the beginning since the it was
like I think I have not watched this
since July of 2020. I have not watched
World News Tonight guys I've been
watching World News Tonight for 20
[__] years every night religiously at
6 30 unless I was working or doing
something stupid guys I have not watched
the news again
it was part of me just disconnecting
there's times I come on here now and I
have no idea what to talk about or
what's going on in the world because I
stop I live my life through 60 minutes
and I live my life through Bill Maher on
Sunday night just a little bit that's
the most politics I could take anyway
and that's the most type of chit chat on
that subject I could take but
[__] I told my wife during the week I
go
still remember us mumbling leaving
like I'm
and we were leaving for various reasons
like I saw things it was just time it
was just time and we were going to leave
anyway but I appreciated how my wife did
it in two weeks before I could even
think of changing my [__] mind
because if you know anything about me
I'm a [__] procrastinator I knew I
had to leave La since 2017 I knew it was
time to go I was overstaying my welcome
but
you wait you think something big is
going to happen and I was telling my
wife the other day I'll never forget
how when I told my agents that I was
leaving how all of a sudden they were
handing me the world but what do you
mean leaving listen let's do this let's
get you on the phone with a [__] and
there was nothing going on nobody was
doing anything nobody was talking there
was maybe five or six comedy clubs open
people were getting covered at the
comedy clubs already
and they're calling me talking to me
about [__]
we're gonna get you a pitch meeting
you're gonna get a show on TV and I'm
like
I'm like Pat Benatar in 84 it's a little
too late Jack
it's a little too late I've been hearing
that story for 10 [__] years I
pitched something the whole thing it's
time to [__] go and next thing you
know we're on a plane but
with all that in mind I want you to
think about how much your life changed
Mike had a day job
Mike had a day job he's Mike have you
ever heard from him again have they ever
called you for your computer no no think
about he'll probably edit this out in
case they watching they're like Mike I
mean bro people just changed think of
how many friends you had
that just [__] changed
think of how you changed deep down
inside I know I [__] changed a ton
without trying
without trying New York I'm gonna start
smoking pot I'm gonna stop eating
Chinese food you know that type of [__]
I'ma stop eating [__] I'm gonna stop
sniffing underwears all that [__]
everything stopped by itself there was
no Focus there was no like you changed
you changed just the amount of coffee I
was drinking
the amount of sleep I was sleeping the
amount of stress I was going under which
I had no idea about you read about
stress as a silent killer you don't have
a [__] clue about stress until the
[__] ship travels I didn't know I was
stressed out I had no [__] idea what
the hell was going on but the pandemic
made me [__] petrified
scared and it opened my eyes it really
did those first two or three months at
home
alone
not seeing your [__] friends talking
to Mike and Lee and Steve Simone and you
know what's going on do you need
anything are you all right like that you
know we were just trying to take care of
each other Lee started walking with
those [__] dudes they were dragging
them along Ventura Boulevard with mask
on it was a [__] trying time think
about this week I want you to really say
to yourself what the [__] did I do
during the pandemic how scared was I how
scared was I I was scared of losing
everything
for starters I got to be honest with you
guys
I was scared of losing my wife
I was really on the brink of losing my
wife not that no no no
I shouldn't say that I wasn't on the
brink of losing my wife
I was it was gonna end bad
if I didn't step away because like for
the first three weeks I just heard from
her I had no idea what to say to my wife
I had no idea like the first two weeks
and finally one day I was in the back
room and I go you know what this is not
a Time
to be isolated from your wife
this is not a time to be
not happy with your significant other
this is not a time for any of this [__]
whether it be parents your brother your
sister this was not a time we were all
so touchy
that it was not a time for me and my
wife to be at each other at all at any
[__] level over anything
I said to myself I'm not going to argue
with them I'm not going to give her a
hard time
in fact I'm gonna be with her a lot more
than I am I mean we were [__] stuck
in a goddamn house
I mean you know I went for a ride once
or twice a day she went for a ride once
or twice a day I started riding my bike
you know I think that's where I changed
the most I looked at my fitness a lot
more in my health we all really started
looking at our fitness and our health
um
we started looking at our futures
I know I did I started looking at my
future going where the [__] are we going
to do here
what the [__] is going on here you know
I looked at my family and I tell you
what where I improved since the pandemic
I'm gonna tell you where I improved so
much because you have to take a mental
you really do have to make a [__] you
have to take like an inventory now and
go what did I learn the last three is
what did I really go through I think I
became a better husband
it forced me to become a better father
taught me how to relax again
it taught me how to sit in a chair
outside and go
okay
it's okay I got nowhere to be and guess
what
the world's not gonna end if I don't get
that
don't don't [__] live with it and
I'll live with it
we were in a rush
from 19 [__] 79 to 2020. I was always
in a rush
always in a [__] Rush
you know I did not know how to even work
out
you know I would go to Jujitsu and I'd
be thinking about the next activity I go
to the gym and in the middle of gym I'd
be thinking about the next activity if I
went to do stand up I wasn't I wasn't
living in the moment anymore I was my
mind was racing and that's never good
I'm not whining guys it was great I had
a good time you know
we accomplished our goals but somewhere
along the line
I think a lot of people not just
comedians I think a lot of people gained
strength through the pandemic as [__]
scary as it was because remember the
only way you get stronger in life is by
moving past something we moved past
something [__] pretty pretty big the
main question is
how are we going to react to the next
one
how it was this a was this a [__]
Prelude yeah was this a Prelude to
something that's going to happen in the
future I mean they're never going to
lock us down again they've now is when
they've learned all the [__] damage
that the lockdown did the kids the
seniors to us our [__] uh immune
systems they found this out so we're
never gonna go locked down again
but think about it if something like
this happens again and people are really
getting sick again and you know we go
back into hospitals I mean you know
we're never going to lay flat and
nobody's going to be dying on Facebook
and all that [__] anymore nobody turned
that into a series I was so in shock
that nobody went out and said give me
all your Facebook memories and let's do
the videos of dying on Facebook I
thought that was going to be a great
sitcom I really did you know come to the
hospital I can't see you but it was sad
I'm just trying to make a joke or
something stupid but it's true I mean
now you have to think about
I'm going to be prepared for the next
time something like this happens
I'm not saying there's going to be
another pandemic I'm not saying that the
bat's getting out you know I'm not
saying three years later it definitely
came from the lab who knows where the
[__] it came from at the end of the day
it don't [__] matter it's how we're
going to react to the next one from how
we what we learned dog I had more fear
than I had ever been in my life looking
back at it now and I'm not ashamed to
[__] say it I developed a [__]
fear early on you know listen man I
listen to white people I don't listen I
don't listen to anybody when it comes to
that type of [__] and I don't know if
you guys notice I'm not trying to be
offensive here or anything but white
people were [__] scared and when
white people are scared I'm scared you
follow what I'm saying to you I don't
give a [__] we were scared there was a
lot of fear going around and for some
people it got into that [__] psyche
and I think at the end of everything
along with the confusion
to [__] withdraw I just it was just
too much for me
and I'm happy look look at all the good
things that came from the pandemic look
at all the [__] there's a lot
[__] happy you just don't have
to go to work no more
[Music]
or a better job yeah or you got better
jobs
you know your hours are different
your relationships are different you
know you know if you look at big
everything's different now
you know how you look at the holidays
right you want to I gotta prepare for
the [__] holidays I gotta make sure
not to get covered in November
so I could be able to go to my Boogaloo
[__] classes in December you gotta
look at life a lot [__] differently
man
but I'm happy that we adjusted
I'm happy that we made it through but
that's food for the thought Food For
Thought this week three [__] years
ago we were going through
we [__] I went through a week of
right now I was going through hell three
years ago right now it was Thursday
and they would I was gonna leave on a
plane fried already canceled Nyack
two nights in Nyack
I [__] pulled it off and then that
Friday I was supposed to come to New
York City wait all weekend then shoot
The Sopranos on Monday and Tuesday Saint
Patty's and the day afterward
and when they [__] called me at six
o'clock because Bernthal already John
burnt had already negotiated for them to
fly us in a private plane and I was
still [__] petrified
and I'll never forget when I landed when
Monday came
I got the report out of New York about
Michael Yo
Michael Yo had been a bad [__] shape
and I was like you know I said a prayer
for Michael Yo but at the same time I
was like
that could have been me last week in New
York City and the [__] freak of that
week
I gotta admit to you you know I don't
know about the Mickey Mantle Gene and
that New York City got hit hard and that
week bird Chrysler was in New York that
whole week and he went to a Nick game
I'll never ever forget this [__] that
[__] went to a nickname and they
caught him on the Jumbotron like
Wednesday night when the [__] city
was petrified the numbers are going up
and here's Bert with a beer that was
half full and he went over to somebody
and like three people poured their beers
in there and drank it and I'm like I'm
turning this off because that
[__] is dying right there that
[__] is dead and he lived
through it so Bert really does have the
Mickey Mantle Gene I'll tell you what
else popped up from this [__]
pandemic that was that's also great
better help and a bunch of companies
like them that just cater with you now
online and while we have it how about a
quick word from our sponsors let's go to
bed out what's happening you Savages
this episode of The Joint is what
brought to you by better help as humans
we don't know it all in fact we're
learning new things every day about
ourselves and therapy can be a helpful
tool to deepen that understanding of who
you are and what your purpose is listen
during the pandemic life whatever I got
all confused and better help help me out
a lot Dana was my therapist at the time
she took a time she gave me a little
assignments to do and today I live
anxiety free every once in a while I get
a little fear but I do my little
exercises and it's tremendous now better
help is online therapy option that's
convenient it's flexible affordable and
entirely done online what you're going
to do is you're going to fill out a
brief questionnaire get matched with a
licensed therapist and if you don't like
that therapist you can switch at any
time for an additional charge discover
your potential with better help I did
visit betterhelp.com
Diaz today Diaz to get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com
Diaz and now back to the show
all right we're back enough of that
[__] depressing [__] uh whatever
talk I don't know if you guys been on a
different planet this week
well something else happened this week
in the music industry that was very sad
and that's my man uh
I think his name is
what the [__] was his name yeah
Washington whatever Gary Washington
passed away to some people nobody gave a
[__] he was just a rather another
redneck to me no no this week I had to
reflect on that and go
that was the last of the original
members
that's it those [__] you know
listen guys I love how we throw away we
throw these words away now like this is
history this is Monumental you know this
is epic you know five of the best
comedians on the same build this is
[__] history
will you give me a [__] break you
give me a [__] break with your
history [__] things you know it's
history LeBron James tickets are going
for seven thousand dollars are you
[__] crazy I could count less LeBron
James falls off the back of the [__]
bus whatever the [__]
cheer enough already you know
all these people have this fake history
in their mind like that's historic you
know I want no you're [__] [__]
you're [__] [__]
history is
such a thing that's like you know
nobody gives a [__] at the end of the
[__] week I'm gonna tell you what
history was
history is
three or four dirty [__] dudes
from wherever there was Jacksonville
Florida or I don't know they were
somewhere down there
that put together a sound
that you'll never duplicate again like
it was never done like I was sitting
there the other day reading about this
guy thinking to myself
so before 1973 nobody did Southern Rock
like nobody did Southern [__] rock
like that's what you're trying to tell
me but the rockabilly's got to be
something in there like rockabilly
became that you know there's got to be
different fusions of music that became
that and then the years later now people
arguing about whether it's a country or
country rock or southern rock you know
what it was let me tell you what Lynyrd
Skynyrd was come here they were a foster
[__] nature and guess what it'll
never [__] happen again
just like Nirvana will never happen
again and led zeppel never happened
again and bands like the Rolling Stones
or just some band that you might like
that had a unique sound it's never going
to happen again
I was there guys I'm not going to tell
you that I was jumping up and down when
the Leonard Skynyrd first released that
album or I knew you know I was dead when
they sung Freebird you know I'm not
gonna tell you none of that [__] but I
still remember the reaction that these
[__] bands were given I grew up
in North Bergen New Jersey [__] and
you know it's blue collar so why the
[__] with southern music be up in blue
collarville you know what I'm saying
wait are you with me [__] why
the [__] would we be playing Molly
Hatchet and the Allman Brothers and uh
you know the Marshall Tucker Band and
[__]
if you want me to come out and yell at
you and go I was right there I loved all
those bands no I didn't but they did had
some badass jams and their attitudes
were [__] stronger than the rock guys
we came up to love Molly had attach it
Flirting With Disaster come on dog these
these bands were [__] Marshall Tucker
Band these guys drank for [__] days
okay there was no political correctness
there was no party there was no showers
there was nothing there was [__]
syphilis getting [__] in the ass
drinking and playing a [__] banjo
you ever [__] doubt me you go on
YouTube and you go on a [__] Lynyrd
Skynyrd
you watch them live from [__] Asbury
Park it's a black and white footage you
watch these [__] and you're
like and then you go on Showtime or
whatever that documentary's on Netflix I
think it is about the drummer or
whatever
you know you go on there and you take a
look at that [__] and you're like what
the [__] were they doing
the documentary about the stones telling
them and net worth not the walk on the
tongue and they went out there and not
walked on the tongue but stepped on the
[__] tongue
damn it if that doesn't make you proud
to be an American I don't know what does
they didn't give a [__]
all these fake people that you see I
don't give a [__] the guys they did not
give a [__]
September 77 go to [__] them from the
Oakland Coliseum tell me they gave a
[__] on that stage tell me they got a
memo from somebody tell me that I'd love
for you to [__] tell me that they
didn't give a [__] that was the 70s
we're playing music we're catching VD
with [__] smoking dope we're drinking
and we're gonna play all [__] night
[__] the union [__] the guys and say you
got to get off that stage at 1am it was
a different [__] time guys
I mean I listen I would love to tell you
that I grew up on the Allman Brothers No
I didn't no I didn't but I listened to
them growing up and even then I was like
this ain't my favorite music
but I got a mental I gotta make a mental
note this [__] is [__] interesting
you know whip whipping post and all that
[__] and live from The Beacon Theater
very interesting music you know you get
Molly Hatchet listen I know Flirting
With Disaster or whatever but they had
another album that was [__]
tremendous you know I can't remember the
name of it right now what was another
out there was another southern rock
album that I had at the house that you
know this ain't the [__] you're gonna
play at a party in North Bergen this
ain't the [__] you're gonna hear in a
club in New York City but this is the
[__] you listen to in your basement when
you're smoking dope and you're like
wow what the [__] is this you know I
still remember Eddie telling me a
[__] story about
um
kiss
how he had to sneak his albums home
and put them under a shirt and [__] and
bring them in the house and listen to
them when
when nobody was home listen
nice that's that's all our stories
you know I feel bad for the Youth of
America today that they can't bring an
album
put it on a jukebox or whatever you know
you gotta you got your tray of CDs or
whatever the [__] you got your iPhone
everything is on iPhone and Spotify but
just to feel these albums this is why
when I was doing the album of the week
on patreon I really enjoyed it because I
wanted you to feel these albums I wanted
you to look in the album you know when
you put a song on Spotify I I hear the
song I hear the guitar licks I hear the
lyrics I hear the the production of it
it's great
but once I look at the album I'll
understand your band a lot better
once I look at the little diagrams that
you made in your stupid [__] album
and the pictures that you put in there
really your [__] bummy friend
sleeping with dirty feet
I'm not here to criticize it I'm just
telling us that that was our podcast of
you
when we were growing up that was our
podcast you know there was no internet
there was cream there was rolling stone
and there was the album
and that five minutes when you just open
the album and read the things and oh you
know we want to thank all the Hilton
Hotels and [__] like that that was our
little podcast we had to develop a
[__] story from what we read in that
diagram they just set out like a
a thing for you you know like with the
connected dots and you gotta [__]
connect them on your own
so that was what made us tick so
you know music has changed a lot this I
mean I think uh I think just a cover
band now
and they've been a cover band for like
20 years with the existing members I
mean it's not really the brother the son
the nephew you know and it's pretty
impressive and [__] but they could go on
forever and they're probably going to go
on forever and I support them going on
forever
but in reality that movement that I
experienced growing up you guys are
experiencing something else you're
experiencing post Malone and you know
with his light little [__] loafers
and and you know Harry Styles with a
dress on you guys are experiencing that
and God bless you guys it's not for me I
got to experience something that was
hard
dirty gritty
and I mean you know when I think of the
albums that changed that molded me into
liking music
it's got to be Led Zeppelin too dirty
It's gotta be that one you know I can't
remember all these albums now off the
top of my head it's got to be those
early Sabbath things but at the same
time it's got to be two for the Road by
Lynyrd Skynyrd it's got to be Give Me
Back My Bullets because I had to Give Me
Back My Bullets before I had two for the
road and any other one of their albums I
love that [__] album giving Back My
Bullets you know
and then comes to whatever the street
survive is another piece of great
[__] work
listen well people there was a band a
couple years ago that my friend John uh
Hayes his son was in it and they had
that Marshall Tucker sound but I don't
think it will ever come back and I don't
think that you know right now you have
like who's the pretty girl that every
Monday morning I gotta wake up and she
[__] thrilled people with her hot
pants on she got on stage with Axel Rose
and she's great I'm not saying that
she's great I forget you know there's a
lot of female country singers there's
Chris Stapleton there's a lot of great
country people right now but that's not
Leonard Skinner
and that's not going to be the Allman
Brothers and I like them jelly roll I
[__] love jelly roll the reason I dig
jelly roll as much as I do because his
his voice reminds me of Greg Waldman
he's white but he sings Black and it's
not black it's his [__] soul that
he's throwing out there for you
[__] for you to you know take a
look at and go okay
but it's uh
again I could lie to you people there's
you know I'm depressed about God I put
the picture up of him when I went to sin
I'm not doing any of that I'm just
letting you know that in reality
it's the end of a [__] error you know
Ozzy him I mean I'm looking at these
bands that are going out this year
there's a lot of bands that are going
out this year that this might be the
last time they go out guys
I just heard the other day that kiss is
doing Madison Square Garden
for December the final time
two two shows this is the last last last
last last time to level [__] do that
[__]
but now and you know what man I can't
imagine like when this guy went down I
was thinking about kiss because I had
heard it that day I think on any trunks
radio show
well I was thinking about
the day when Gene Simmons passes
how many people are going to be [__]
like just blown away and even though
kiss isn't putting out no music or
anything like that they did the damage
they had to do you know Ace Freely I
know that uh Ace Freely was at some
place in La two weeks ago and Dean said
he missed it and he was pissed off
because he went you know Ace is
tremendous but you know pretty soon all
these guys going to be drying up I mean
we still got Keith we still got Mick
Jagger we still you know we still got a
lot of great guys but in reality they're
getting [__] old and they can't hop
around like they [__] used to the
energy they had
they're not used to it so
like I said a thousand times I'm gonna
go right now as it is so far I'm going
to see
somebody I really want to go see I want
to go see uh quiet right with Mike May
2nd or something like that the UFC's
going on sale Friday from May 6. I don't
even know who's on the card I just saw I
thought it was Oliveira but it's not
yeah in Newark in Newark so
I I don't know if it's a [__] late
card I can't be that until
if they start at seven I'll be there but
at ten o'clock I have a rough time with
Tyler especially Saturday nights I watch
The Honeymooners with them this weekend
the [__] guys I had a great time with
her Saturday was a shitty [__] day
I had plans to go meet my teacher Mr
Barone drop off a book on them maybe go
to lunch but it was just shitty they
said it was going to rain up north it
was going to snow up North so I'm like
what the [__] am I gonna do
so I go you know what maybe I'll go see
Creed because Creed came out this week
guys I gotta get back into the movies
I'm not going to sit here we can talk
[__] to you people that the movie suck
but then again I'm not getting [__]
into them so I said you know what
I'm gonna get back into going to movies
again because my wife told me uh John
Wick 4 is coming out there's a couple
movies that are coming out
so she goes where are you going to
movies with [__] hold on oh my God
movies with but myself I got a hand so I
go down there I stop at Kings get some
Chinese food now [__] uh
come up you know and she goes did you
ask mercy and I'm like Mercy is not
going to want to go see [__] Creed
it's because you never know ask him
Michael would be Jordan and he's in
Black Panther she likes all that stuff
so I go Mercy you want to go see Creed
with me she's like the new Creed I go
yeah she goes yeah I'll go see it which
I go oh [__] all right I had to run
around I had to go work out and [__] I
got home I took a shower I got dressed I
go let's get the [__] out of here we
went to Red Robin in East uh Brunswick
went to Red Robin
we had a [__] classic cheeseburger
we went in there you know the movie
theater was [__] empty but this is a
14 movie theater like they have 14
movies in this place
so I was a movie theater 10. it was
probably seated 60 people there's
probably 15 people now we bought a thing
of popcorn she got it huh nice nice
seats comfortable we bought a thing of
popcorn we bought some [__] she got a
Slurpee I got a Coke Zero and I watched
the [__] movie was an Academy Award
winner no but it was entertaining and
while I was sitting there I got the
temps I got to spend time with my
daughter and we watched him we giggled
and [__]
half hour trailers
two o'clock movie time 2 30 is when the
[__] movie started not mad you know
not mad at all but it's just funny that
but I will tell you what I did notice
movies are back
there's a bunch of good movies coming
out uh but they got their step back they
got it back
they got they learned how to work with
covert they said [__] it
good movies are coming out one movie's
coming out that the guy called me and
offered me a day in it but he offered to
me like the week before like he called
me like today for like next Tuesday oh
no for Thursday it was like Monday he
called he goes can you be in California
on Thursday it's a movie called
Sweetwater about the New York Knicks and
basketball there's some good [__]
movie there's a movie about night coming
out about Michael Jordan with uh
the whole crew from [__] Goodwill
Hunting and you know all of America's
best that new movie I'm not gonna go see
it but Jesus Christ what's the one with
Paul Walker that he died Fast and
Furious it's the last one
Jesus Christ those guys made a ton of
money what's his name looks [__] old
Vin Diesel yeah oh my God if you think I
look old that [__] looks old but
uh the movie looks okay Aquaman's in it
you know that big [__] my War The
Other Guys in it I can't wait to take my
son to see Super Mario Super Mario's
coming out I think Sebastian's in it
yeah Sebastian's movies coming out the
[__] machines coming out I put the
trailer up the other day so the movies
are back so I got my little hobby again
going to the movie theater sitting there
with an edible in me and [__] just
dreaming and that's it you bad
[__] it's Monday the 13th of
March a little Monday motivation for you
and that's it I ain't laying no claims I
ain't [__] doing dick it's a
beautiful day to be alive
I'm feeling better I'm looking better
and just food for thought three years
ago today or tomorrow the pandemic shut
everything down how much did you [__]
change in those three years
stay black have a great week and I'll
see you [__] next week Tip Top
Magoo and now for a word my
[__] sponsors Jack
you bad Savages thank you very much for
taking the air beat from Uncle Joey
today
collington's is in my uh in my prayers
but anyway
don't forget this Saturday
the day after the Irish disaster of Life
UFC 20
28 in the welterweight champ will be
decided in London chip chip Charlie ho
Leon Edwards against Kamara Usman placed
200 on any bet and get 200 and bonus
bets instantly and all users you got to
do the same game parlays the more legs
you add the more gears you win but it
starts with you download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app use code Joey j-o-e-y but
five bucks on UFC 286 and get 200 and
bonus bets instantly that's called Joey
only at DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
UFC you got to be 21 or over most
eligible States but age varies in by
jurisdiction eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply see DraftKings
Sportsbook for state-specific
responsible gambling resources you got a
gambling problem call 1-800 gamlib not
download the app and let's get ready for
UFC e 286 the joint is also brought to
you by Mint mobile listen are you
spending too much money on your phone
plan it's over save more and spend less
with mint mobile mint is the first
service company to sell wireless cell
service online only get a new phone plan
starting at 15 a month who's better than
you nobody with all that extra cash what
are you gonna do you can take a jet to
your next party all plans come with
unlimited talk text and high speed data
on the nation's largest 5G Network you
could switch easily in minutes get to
your new Wireless plan right now for 15
a month that's it
and the plan shipped to your door for
free go to mintmobile.com Joey again
that's mintmobile.com Joey cut your
wireless bill at 15 a month at
mintmobile.com slash Jerry I want to
thank
better help I want to thank DraftKings
and I want to thank mobile most
importantly I want to thank you savages
for having my back stay black have a
great week and I'll see you next Monday
tip top Magoo
foreign
[Music]